[Music]
all right so we had a beautiful spring
yes
windy for the allergy sufferers but that
happens each and every year but the
spring lasted
it played for a while brought in some
cool temps heated up
cooled down and now we've entered
summertime you're absolutely right
right it's been a little late to get
this 100 view temperature and i'm not
complaining
i love showing you my temperatures
because here you have the best reactions
right when i show her the temperatures i
almost want to use them as ringtones
for yeah we're bringing back the heat
but i just told her and i'm going to
tell you wait till you see that eight
day forecast because there are some
changes
even after the heat live look outside
now as we take a look at the las vegas
strip notice there are clouds mixed in
with
sunshine out there we'll call it partly
cloudy skies latest pollen report olive
grasses and ragweed
are our highest readings right now but
they're only in the moderate range right
now
all of course are tree pollen and that's
up to moderate air quality
remains good despite the ozone up to
high 104 in sky canyon right now along
with centennial hills
double nines for you for spring valley
102 for north las vegas and downtown
103 for the east side sunrise manor and
same for whitney ranch and green valley
102 for henderson 98 mountains edge and
104
for southern highlands how about outside
of town 101 for prompt 97 indian springs
102 up there in northeast clark and 113
already for death valley no thank you
all right southwest radar we're looking
at clouds all over us at this hour notes
are coming from the north that's because
we have a low situated to the south of
us
but we're really tracking that high
that's to the northwest of us
and this is allowing nice weather clear
weather all the way up to vancouver
island vancouver canada
they're even getting some clear skies
you can see mount rainier from in
seattle
because it's clear futurecast does show
some clouds though we think they're
going to roll through
tomorrow that'll give us another mix of
clouds and sun
winds for tomorrow pick up just a little
bit but we're still anticipating a light
breeze for your wednesday
stronger winds will come thursday and
friday but that will just be breezy
but the stronger winds do come we think
next week
signifying another change in the
temperatures in fact look at our record
numbers here for these next few days
we'll come very close
to record territory for wednesday
thursday and friday and even our
overnight lows
and we'll start to see these numbers
start to drop saturday and sunday
overnight 79 degrees mostly clear and
mild
overnight so your morning temperature
not too bad 106 for tomorrow we'll see
clouds in the morning and then sun later
on in the day
our record is 107 so we're going to come
very close to that record tomorrow
that was set back in 2003. now here's
your eight day forecast heat warnings we
know that
all the way through friday that should
be allowed to expire because numbers
will start to drop saturday and sunday
next week we'll usher in some cooler
weather another system will roll through
and knock us back to the mid 90s
next week and that actually is going to
be below normal
another great reaction from kier i wish
we could have shown that reaction
i got an applause i love it all right
we'll have more in your forecast coming
up i got a lot more to talk about